today's one minute monday is trust
your team if you want to build a
successful company you have to realize
that you can't
do everything yourself this is a huge
challenge for a lot of entrepreneurs
you hold on to all the responsibility
all the decision making everything runs
through you
and you become this huge bottleneck for
your business
and that makes you unable to grow unable
to accomplish your big goals
because you don't allow your team to
take responsibilities you have to
understand
that you can't do everything yourself if
you want this company to grow
now i'm in asia right now well not here
but while you're watching this i'm in
asia i'm on a couple week
trip and i don't really have access to
my
email that much i can't get access to
youtube and facebook so i'm i'm kind of
shut out
and and i'm trusting my team to run my
business for me
for the next couple weeks while i'm away
and and it is scary
it's you know i'm a little nervous i i i
want to be able to see what's happening
but at the same time i trust my team and
i give them responsibilities
you have to remember that if you want to
achieve something big
it requires people who are thinking for
themselves who are making decisions for
themselves
to let you focus on the things that
you're best at and the big picture stuff
so do something small even today to
trust your team give them a little bit
more leash
let them make a little bit more
decisions and let them feel rewarded
trust your team believe